[Music]
please welcome my friend everybody rory
scoville ricegum
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't you don't smell
like i would think you would smell no
and that's what i'm known for
that's why i'm on the show tonight
you sense you don't smell bad you smell
like a tear-free shampoo
i don't know if that's that's like a
when you say to someone you don't know
if that's good or bad yeah like you
smell like a tear-free shampoo that
someone's only reaction has to be
neutral they're like
well
it's a riddle yeah it's like a minotaur
socializing yeah it's only later driving
home you ask your wife like did he
insult me
did he insult me in front of that whole
group i never would you're a well-kept
man i was uh we talked a little bit
backstage i said that i always feel like
you you're from i believe different
people are from different time periods
and i can ask you a question yes sir
when i hugged you right then i stepped
on your shoe you did yeah and i've done
that with other people and i never know
if i should correct it so that moment i
just stayed standing on your shoe
and i just want you to know that i know
it happened yeah
and i'm not ashamed of my choice i'm not
ashamed of your choice either for that
brief moment i felt like you were a
little girl and i was the granddad and
we were dancing
i was just having a great moment i did
feel that way my face was buried in your
chest yeah
i was like this is what it's like to be
a granddaughter
that's an experience i can give people a
as a giant man
i don't often i'm not enveloped often
you know what i mean right you're a tall
fella but you still you're in an
envelopable rage
range that's like another one i'm like
did he insult me
he inserted me in front of those people
you see envelopable
that's not he knows i know that's not a
word
you smell like johnson and johnson no
more tears
and i can eclipse you with my body yeah
welcome to the show yeah
has anyone got this relaxed when they've
sat here before there are different ways
you can go about it
it makes me feel the goofiest
this makes me feel like i'm here to
promote a book
yes it's a novel
i like how close you are yeah you just
got married did you get married in these
shoes
yeah
yeah i did
did you know why you're laughing i did
and this shirt you think i just owned
tons of clothes
this shirt and these jeans is very
casual
it's very casual what did you
i can't tell what you're using foolery i
did i did get married in these shoes
and this shirt
i'm going to be buried in this shirt
that's not a bad shirt not a bad shirt
to be dead in yeah
i love where that's good not a bad shirt
to be dead in
dot net dot net dot com was taken
yeah someone had already got dot org all
of them are taken
that dead in this shirt
[Music]
you